un espoir de vie sous les décombres un
mois après l'explosion du port de la
ville
c'est sous ce bâtiment complètement
détruit en périphérie qu'un chien
renifleur et des scanners thermiques ont
réussi à détecter des battements
cardiaques
il est clair qu'il y à quelque chose et
nous sommes ici avec sept matches mais
pour des recherches supplémentaires
il semble qu'il y ait un ou deux
cadavres et peut-être aussi des vivants
car un coeur bat encore des équipes de
sauvetage libanaise mais aussi
chiliennes se sont rendues sur les lieux
un travail en tandem qui fonctionne bien
mais alors que des équipes de sauveteurs
chilienne débuter les opérations l'armée
libanaise serait intervenu pour y mettre
fin
invoquant la nuit tombante et la
dangerosité de travailler sans grue nous
sommes sûrs qu'il n'y a rien mais si
l'équipe chilienne est sur le point de
trouver quelque chose nous n'allons pas
rester les bras croisés en même temps
nos équipes travaillent toujours avec
l'armée dans le port en fait il
travaillait toute la journée quand
tout-à-coup l'armée a pris une décision
la construction est dangereuse ils
veulent que le travail c'est ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de grue puisque quelqu'un
apparemment responsable de la défense
civile est venue et a dit nous
apporterons une grue à 8 heures du matin
cette personne qui est encore en vie
même si c'est un chat êtes un esprit on
ne veut pas stoppé les recherches
il est interdit d'arrêter le travail et
de se résigner pourquoi ne font-ils pas
leur travail
un mois sous les décombres nous avons
nettoyé les rues reconstruit des
bâtiments et des maisons
fournit des toits pour abriter les
sinistrés de la nourriture des boissons
des médicaments
nous avons tout fait c'était pourtant
leur mission et ils n'ont rien fait si
la foule est en colère et souhaite la
poursuite du travail des sauveteurs pour
les membres de la protection civile
libanaise il s'agit d'une situation
complexe
si l'espoir est de 1% ce pourcentage
nous nous y accrochons car peut-être que
ce film nous conduira à quelque chose de
plus important nous estimons à 99% qu'il
n'ya rien mais à cause de celui qui
reste nous sommes obligés de rester à ce
jour sept personnes seraient encore
portées disparues
cette annonce fait donc rejaillir
l'espoir de survivants l'explosion du 4
août à tuer 191 personnes étaient plus
de 6000
en 100 blessés